we are having fun it's so much fun it's
having so much fun we are making crazy
threats
hopefully they crash and burn and we are
getting mysterious drama freaking trust
me plus a poop deck it's time for roses
and roses a hi everybody it's lauren
zima coming to you not from a poop deck
thank you guys so much for being here we
are recapping reviewing and refilling to
episode three of Fulton Underwood season
of The Bachelor and what fun it was
I loved this episode of love I loved
Colton I love these ladies what did you
guys think is this season getting better
and better with each passing piratey
moment poop jacked right over there
let's get to it last week was a little
dramatic so first of all we start with
even though I'm having fun the montage
of the saddest-looking people by the
pool everybody looks sad can you not
find your sunscreen can you not find
your tanning oil
are you hungry I don't know it's
something Chris Harrison comes in and he
just starts listing dates so this week
three days just drink every time Chris
Harrison's like there's a date coming to
group dates amazing romantic one-on-one
date oh my gosh and you guys after we
got teased the pageant queen versus
pageant queen drama of Hanna B versus
Kalyn and you know they clearly don't
want to be with each other at all I
can't believe they got put on a group
date together
shocking drink if you were shocked I was
so shocked by that mmm
what is this pageant drama between the
two of them we're gonna get into it more
but I am so ready to know what really
happened
by the way my nose hair on this like old
timey paddle I'm gonna I'll report out I
gotta find out what happened between
Hanna being and Kalyn over at the beauty
pageant aha I'm inside sources the judge
the hairdresser the
for what I've lost I haven't anyway so
next up we are going on a group date to
be pirates
question mark where was this what were
we doing drink every time you never
understand the parameters of these dates
I'm like what's happening here truly the
most I can figure out is that it's some
kind of medieval times but with pirating
coltan is a pirate Chris Harrison is
having a lot of fun with doing this
voiceover pirate coltan calls them all
knucklehead that's not a pirate term is
it thank you
say something about like I don't know
your peg leg or your parent you're all
parrots I'm lost where's Johnny Depp
when you need him
did no one come to save me just because
they missed me oh my god do not drink
every time this episode we get
absolutely literary commentary from the
ladies don't drink every time they say
fun you guys don't do it it was really
really really fun I just want to let you
guys know how much fun I've had today
one is I think so much right yeah like
yeah fun day so much fun it ain't really
fun no fun hey who's there the best time
it's so much funny that you under there
oh my gosh you're funny I had so much
honestly what are the words could we say
other than fun enjoyable a good time
happy scintillating dynamic bold dark
deep a black hole a spiral a downward
spiral that foray into the universe from
which we shan't never return that took a
turn anyway so today's gonna be fun but
Vince was in revolver fun this episode
were some absolutely frightening claims
and statements like Demi calling herself
cutthroat kind of chick
next never last episode Emmy said she
was ready to see her enemies meet their
demise happily watched their demise
I'm loving watching dummy dummy dummy
dummy dummy to me more to me the bottle
tough call let me know which one is it
dummy or dummy hi I'm Jimmy Burnett
drink if I got it wrong and please drink
responsibly and be a responsible cut
throat kind of chicken I don't want to
be another one of those yo ho ho's we
are an annus a quote that haenam monster
is gonna come out and then you know the
pirate dick got kind of violent again
I'm not really sure what the competition
was or what you won but they were like
hitting each other I couldn't tell if
anyone was really going to their full
strength of course Kaelyn and Hannah
we're up against each other and Kaelyn
kept saying Hannah was so strong and
you're strong I know you're strong I
don't know it didn't seem like she was
really getting into it she wasn't like I
always wonder about the liability issues
on these dates then Hannah says I didn't
come here to compete in another pageant
Hannah that's what this is you're on a
competition show where you're competing
against other women you're wearing gowns
you're performing talents you're
answering questions about yourself this
is literally in many ways a beauty
pageant here you're in it deal oh and I
wrote down poop deck lol they're just
funny the poop deck right over there
so Hannah starts to spiral drink every
time things get ominous mmm it brings
out all of my insecurities and I start
to spiral and we heard today was really
really really fun I just want to let you
guys know how much fun I had
coal's and said how much fun I had today
I'm gonna look it up we've got it just
let's just throw it out there let's put
it out into the stratosphere synonym
this for fun
amusement pleasant boisterous witty
merry entertaining anyway hopefully they
crash and burn
Demi again she's hoping everybody
crashes and burns I just personally
think when I was younger I thought I
liked a certain type and I always date
at the same time then we get Demi versus
Tracy again I'm pretty much already over
this like I said I'm over the age issue
I don't like Demi slamming people
because they're older I don't like Tracy
slamming dummy because she's younger but
Tracy is dressed like Carmen Sandiego
and where in the world is her common
sense you know I just I don't know what
she's saying anymore and I feel like I
don't know anything about Tracy other
than that she's coming for Demi and it's
never good when your entire identity in
the house and on the show is just who
you're coming for like with Demi I know
she's do another crazy crap you know
she's like in the robe
she's Sparky she's real real sexual but
I don't know anything else about Tracy
and you don't want to be somebody
pitting yourself against someone else in
the beginning keep the focus on the lead
what do you guys think is Tracy's time
coming up soon I am so much funding so
yeah Demi proves you know more about
what she's bringing to the table when
she paddles cold and spanked I want to
read this was my favorite quote of the
night Colton I'm blindfolded and bending
over yeah
Demi does stand out I agree with Demi
about her ability to stand out actually
you know what drink every time there
just was a quote of the night because
what Hannah said oh that's coming up
next Kailyn and Colton are chatting and
they're kissing and Hannah thinks B
fumbled is a word I'm Mike
on board okay I don't know another word
befuddled that's throwing it out there
synonyms include confused unaware be
fumbled not a word
well I think I'd like talk to you about
something well what do you mean want to
talk to me about okay
then Hannah does the Tracy thing this is
such a signature mistake error a lapse
in judgment to bake in the beginning I'm
all about synonyms tonight drink every
time we've got synonyms mm-hmm
look I'm not saying I'm perfect like a
few minutes ago I said that unaware was
a synonym for befuddled and it's not
really confused is journalism the
synonyms include writer of synonyms and
glue the first draft of history
god I'm really out of soapbox now okay
so Hanna makes the mistake of hitting
herself against Kalin of not focusing on
Colton of going to Colton to talk about
Kailyn and when you do that you just
look petty don't you it always is
encouraged under the umbrella of like
you've got to tell him or her if there's
somebody who's really shouldn't be here
and isn't here for the right reasons but
you just end up looking like a crazy
person because it becomes a game if she
said she said and that's what this turns
into manipulation deceitfulness
manipulative toxic not manipulative
it's lies and then cold and just like I
don't know what I believe huh anyway
also how about that never been kissed
cow Heather really encouraging Hanna
multiple times drink every time she was
like encouraging Hanna to just walk
right into the fire with gold are you
gonna tell him the truth about the
situation rescue it who knows what she's
talking about but she's not saying she
loves you my fear is that she's gonna go
talk crap about you and then he's gonna
believe that mm-hmm
there's things that like I haven't like
talk to you about Pat has been like
traumatic experiences in my life that
declared me I loved the way that Colton
handled this with Kaylin he went ahead
and he gave her the Rose mm-hmm
and Hanna didn't get a kiss yikes
I was so painful she even said not even
a peck Jamie Lee's the bear said it was
include smooch anyway please
then we have a one-on-one with Elise who
is in her 30s like Tracy but acts like
an adult
unlike Tracy sorry Tracy you're not
you're not doing great
I like ELISA Lodge we get our first
helicopter of the season and apparently
the first helicopter of Elise and
Colton's lives they never didn't find
before you do have an age difference
again Elise brings up the age difference
snakes near where we're all going on and
they go to a an amusement park in San
Diego where the premise is that kids get
brought to the amusement park
I got a say okay this these two have an
age difference we don't know where
they're both out if they're in different
life places kids get thrown into the mix
it felt a little obvious but it's fine
because the kids were so cute and I love
that we talked about Colton's charity
because he is doing great work there and
I applaud him and again I think Elise is
great I love the conversations they had
what did you guys think of a lease and
Colton's connection I felt like at
dinner they had a really good chat all
day long like it felt real it was
grounded and real and I liked these
talks let me know anything also drink
every time somebody says the word
smitten this season I'm a smitten kin
right now lessons
we used to be friends like also want a
whispering well doing a lot of
whispering especially with us like
Hannah Kaelyn saying or having to get a
lot of closed captions so don't drink
every time you see our cousin's
dangerous
they talk about me talking about the
fact that I hate one another reality
must be a pageant situation what's gonna
happen I need to penetrate I'm a
journalist what's the truth anyway my
sister is a labor and delivery nurse and
she was married oh and then of course at
least telling this story about her
sister which is just horrible and I so
feel for her on this but it just was a
real conversation it was good it was
unlike some other conversations we had
this episode then we get the next group
date and the ladies sock cold and
shirtless for the first time yes as the
audience we had seen kolten in the
shower but the ladies had yet to see him
this season of filming with his shirt
off how do I know cuz a shameless plug I
was there yes if you zoom in on some of
the gym of parts I think you can see my
feet et was exclusively on the set of
this date had to et online.com for
interviews with kolten with Cassie with
Katherine with many of Louie's Oh Chris
Harrison two ladies to the bachelor
it's a strongest woman competition with
Terry Crews and his wife who are so
fabulous I've interviewed that many
times shameless they really love each
other and I love the message of this
behind every man a strong woman
this group dates parameters were more
clear it was like literally a
competition a relay Catherine revealing
she was a black belt I do martial arts
for almost ten years
I'm expected but Katherine was our
villain on night one and then she's like
really disappeared falling off the face
of the earth
and I wish I could have seen her be more
black belt II we didn't even get to see
the moves by my side calling the action
today the legend the Hall of Famer
himself Fred Willard they had fun I love
when they bring Fred Willard on he's so
funny and I thought the competitions
were fun the cake pull of the engagement
ring toss the limo pull what did you
guys think did you like this group date
I'm not totally sure how the finalists
were chosen but it was fun fun enjoyable
entertaining witty marvelous fab okay
don't drink every time they say strong
I'm showing this woman drawing a lot of
strong confident women in my life I'm so
like I said we got this great
conversation with Colton and Elyse
earlier and then we get Kaitlyn like I
was kind of falling behind and I'm
really excited to be able to have some
sort of opportunity to get to chat with
him a little bit I think her name is
Kaitlyn I don't know for sure
why don't I know because Kaitlyn doesn't
want to tell you anything about herself
with Kaitlyn I mean right now our
relationship romantically is behind the
others
Colton sits down with her she's been
talking about how she wants more time
with him she's worried about falling
behind well she gets her chance she gets
her moment she is sitting down with The
Bachelor and what does she say
anything like happen in my life that
like is standing out for me right now
that like I want to share with you okay
I'm drowning here I'm drowning Kalin
what are you doing this is maybe the
worst conversation I've truly ever heard
on The Bachelor like there have been bad
conversations with drama and with
horrible things said and with tears but
this is just a bad conversation other
than the fact they're like tame scream
and by that I mean no thoughts ideas or
opinions are being exchanged it's the
literal definition of a bad conversation
there's no two-way street
I mean she straight-up tells them I'm
not really sure what to like open up
about other than the fact they're like
my life has been like good well why are
you here at least share a good story I
don't know where we're going to this
cold news says he's ready to get married
asks her about what she's looking for
and she says I want somebody that's
happy to go out with me and my friends
and have a really ridiculous silly
evening okay girl read the playbook have
you seen the show I was baffled by that
what did you guys think where is this
convo rank for you in terms of the
biggest bomb and not a bomb like you
dropped a bomb and it was interesting a
bomb like things fell apart in tragic
fashion
tonight
I just didn't feel
my best breakfast but you know what I
really admired what Colton did here he
just said bye
good job Colton I was sitting there
screaming at my screen please just send
her home right now
and he did and I don't mean that in a
mean way I just mean I'm glad he had
that clarity and understanding to just
say this isn't gonna work
see you later Gator after a while
Caitlin it's not her name it doesn't it
doesn't
so Nicole gets the roast and then we're
having a pool party and that means there
will be no cocktail party tonight and we
get another moment with Colton and
Hannah gee oh gosh well thank you you
can tell he gave her the first
impression rose and then she didn't get
a date as he explained to her which we
know it's because he knows he likes her
which happens a lot on the show I'm very
confident what we have I get it and in
our chemistry and I know how I feel when
I'm around you what do you think of
Colton Hannah G's connection I wanted to
get a confessional moment from cold and
the baddest feelings for energy because
I think they're strong but I feel like
they probably are holding out on X they
don't want us to be too swayed yet which
we love we'd love to be surprised and
what else am I surprised about well this
is a mystery what happened with Hannah
and Kailyn there's been like a lot of
Petie girls drama things you guys drink
every time they allude but don't tell us
I want to be honest so Hannah and I do
have like a past and it's not like an
easy crazy past by any means mm I just
felt as a viewer watching it
we know they were roommates they were
super close we know that they had a
falling-out those are all the things
that we know we know they're not
speaking to each other anymore but why
we got into this crazy she said she said
place where they were both calling each
other manipulative manipulation
deceitfulness not manipulative she's
manipulative they're fake
and Liars and a bad thing it's just such
a pattern of behavior but what happened
Kailyn did Hannah steal your shoes
before you were supposed to go out
onstage for Miss USA Hannah did
Kailyn tell everyone that you were a
crazy person and that hurt your chances
during the interview portion of Miss USA
I don't know I'm making crap up because
I don't know what happened and I want to
and Colton felt the same way I love this
moment Oh when he went into the control
room we kind of got it behind the
curtains moment I love that Chris
Harrison sat down with them Colton's
confused we're all confused
we need clarity this is a mystery that
needs to be solved it's a mystery we
don't know who was the part who was
responsible who is charged with crimes
those are my notes I was seeing his
report I think fired anyway ethics
okay so Hannah also says drink every
time there's a crazy quote there's a
beautiful monster inside of me and
today we have to let it out okay what
that's dark
I say there's a tank of rage what do you
guys think based on what little we know
are you agreeing with Hannah or Kailyn
whose side are you on
it's true detective season for The
Bachelor
and the detectives are Colton Underwood
and Chris Harrison
then we get rose ceremony number three
and I have to say right as we were
heading into it all the suspense was
being built up about Hanna and Kailyn we
knew he wasn't gonna send Hanna home you
know Kailyn already had a rose so that
was covered from the pirate poopdeck
moment and Hanna was not gonna be sent
home because we still don't have answers
on this pageant queen drama and because
Kailyn has said she will snap and
because Hanna called herself a monster
with a tank of Rage like we got to see
that tank overfilled we got to see it
overrun we got to see it explode so I
knew she wasn't gonna go home but I do
want to applaud both her and Bri on some
interesting turtlenecks that they were
wearing looking great love a rose
ceremony look it's weird Hanna it's like
you put on a dress and stand on a stage
with other women and then your name gets
called it's like a beauty pageant that's
what you came here for I'm not a
darkness there to be figured out I had
something special planned
today and it just doesn't fit wealthy
knowing that I'd never got time to talk
to him on Jenka had some kind of plan he
would have much more enjoyed that than
listening to two pageant girls talking
through their drama for two hours this
was another thing we never got to she
like said she didn't get to act out her
plan and she was upset about it well
what was your plan was it another
noisemaker moment was another drowning
joke I don't know but I do like how
energetic she is she's always up
always ready I love that so shout out to
Anika Jersey
shout out to Demi space after Tracy got
the Rose drink to that I was just funny
mm-hmm lots of girl-on-girl drama this
season like very personal like Tracy and
Demi Hannah and Kailyn Bree and her
accent Cassie in her butterflies I'm
reaching now take care Lucy give her a
big goodbye to Katherine again I was
surprised by this you guys in a good way
I love on the show surprises me after 23
seasons Katherine was kind of our
villain on night one but sent home today
and we never even got to see that black
belt pour one out for Katherine hmm but
I guess she's reunited with her dog also
going home Bree her Australian accent
and Nina her who are you Nina I still
don't know but all I love to you so we
end this episode with Hannah crying
about all the crap people are saying
about her but Hannah I got to call you
out here girl you started it you went to
Colton first so of course people are
talking about you because you began the
conversation two-way street all of this
will be addressed cannot wait to watch
episode 4 what did you guys think of
this episode who do you think Colton
will choose Hannah or Kailyn I won't be
surprised if we get a two-on-one date
and someone's left in a desert or a
forest or some kind of nature and we
love it don't we I love you guys so much
JC's not here today but you know what
let's pull up a picture of them because
we love him and we miss him and it'll be
as if he's here
I don't know where he is crap there's a
picture of JC on my phone somewhere
holding a bottle of Rose day that would
be so I found it okay
so let's pull up a picture of him here
he is we love and we love our boo boo
look at dapper he looked that day was
when he gave me some narrow ball from
their birthday
maralell does not sponsor this podcast
this is not a podcast I've had a lot of
rows hmm okay I spell that myself that's
a good guys love you so much please
continue to send us your thoughts on the
season of The Bachelor love love love
hearing from you more than you know I
just lay awake in bed at night reading
your comments they do is that weird
I don't know love you so much you're so
much fun you're so much fun and I'm
smitten with you all babe
[Music]
let's pull up a picture of him because
we love him crap I take too many
pictures at Marshall's